طلب القضاء التركي اليوم بسجن رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول المعارضه اكرم امام اوغلو احد
ابرز وجوه المعارضه التركيه لمده عام
وثلاثه اشهر على الاقل بتمته اهانه اعضاء
مجلس الاعلى للانتخابات من اسطنبول ينضم
الينا مراسلنا حسين اسد حسين اهلا بك رئيس
بلديه اسطنبول اذا المعارض اكرم امام
اوغلو خب قوسين او ادنى ليدخل السجن بتهمه
اهانه الهيئه العليا للانتخابات هل هي
تهمه سياسيه كما يقول محامون
يعني على الاقل بالنسبه لحزب الشعب
الجمهوري هي مسرحيه وليست محاكمه اكرم
امام اوغلو الذي واجه اردوغان عام 2019
وتمكن من هزيمتي حزب العداله والتنميه
المسيطر على بلديه اسطنبول منذ اكثر من
عقدين فاز
برئاسه البلديه
واعيدت الانتخابات وفاز مره اخرى وبالتالي
هو اسم مهم ومرشح متوقع للرئاسيات
وبالتالي ابعاد امام اوغلو وحظر العمل
السياسي بقرار قضائي يجنب اردوغان مواجهه
ثانيه مع هذا الرجل الذي يحضر بشكل
انتخابات الرئاسيه امام اوغلو ليس همم
القضاء وحده هو ما يواجهه ولكن هو ايضا في
مواجهه مستمره مع الاعلام الموالي للحكومه
والحزب الحاكم هو في مواجهه مستمره مع
الاغلبيه التي تمتلكها همم او التي
يمتلكها حزب العداله والتنميه في بلديه
اسطنبول ما يعيق الكثير من المشاريع التي
يحاول الرجل انجازها هنا في اسطنبول
وبالتالي ان حكم القضاء في هذه القضيه كما
يريد الادعاء بسجن امام اوغلو وحظر العمل
السياسي على هذا الرجل فهذا يعني ابعاد
اسم مهم ومرشح محتمل قوي للرئاسيات اا في
ظل سعي الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان منذ
شهور من خلال حمله انتخابيه غير معلنه
وغير رسميه للفوز بهذه الانتخابات بطبيعه
الحال في التاريخ التركي المعاصر باعتبار
انها تاتي والذكرى المئويه الاولى دي همم
الجمهوريه وتاسيسها الجمهوريه التركيه
وبالتالي عادي هو امر مهم بالنسبه لحزب
العداله والتنميه ولي اردوغان ولكن امام
مغلق وتحدث اليوم قال انه بانتظار ان همم
القضاء من التهم المنسوب اليه التهاميه
اهانه رئيس الهيئه العليا للانتخابات
واعضاء الهيئه بعد تصريحاته عاقبه اعلان
هي في 2019 اعاده الانتخابات قال انه تعرض
للظلم وبالتالي امام مغلي ينتظر حتى
الرابع عشر من الشهر المقبل
لجلسه اخرى في المحاكمه بحثا عن براءته او
ربما يتمكن على ادعاء من ادانه امام مغلق
بالتالي ابعاده بشكل نهائي عن العمل
السياسي خلال الفتره المقبله قبيله
للانتخابات الرئاسيه شكرا لك يا حسين
اسد من